[Musique]
c'était le vendredi 22 mai dernier un
million cinq cent mille masques été
réceptionné par le département
et aujourd'hui c'est le centre
départemental d'incendié et de secours 9
7 4 qui prend une partie du stock que
nous avons travaillé avec les services
de l'état de façon justement donner de
la cohérence à l'utilisation de ces
masques et bien sûr en priorité nous en
avons retenu un certain nombre pour les
besoins de service pour nos partenaires
comme le disent les communes qui
s'approvisionnent depuis ce matin les
ccas centres communaux d'action sociale
donc ce sont les partenaires
institutionnels de la collectivité
départementale que nous servons des
cartons qui font du bien aux personnels
de secours en première ligne depuis le
début du coup vide
c'est un peu comme partout on est tous
dans la même galère
tout le monde doit s'associer pour
éradiquer le phénomène
nous avons en priorité nous aussi la
protection de nos agents qui
interviennent chaque jour
donc c'est important une vision
collective de l'aide publique car même
si le sdiss gère ses propres commandes
ce stock fait du bien ça correspond pas
une urgence mais ça correspond à un
besoin
depuis le début de la crise bien sûr
nous équipons nos personnels de
protection individuelle
et donc on avait si vous voulez un
certain stock qu'on a accusé petit à
petit on l'art est constitué par nos
commandes
la part les commandes personnel 12 10
par contre cette dotation vient à point
nommé parce qu'elle nous permet de
reconstituer nostre ce stock donne de la
perspective à l'action de ses agents
direction le centre de secours de saint
denis
c'est la quête organisée le matériel des
28 centres de secours de lille qui
interviennent chaque jour plus de 150
fois de la c4 virale se ratant tout le
monde on a une pénurie et des
difficultés pour s'approvisionner avec
nos fournisseurs habituels
si la sedre virale persiste on aura
besoin encore pendant plusieurs jours
voire semaines de ces protections pour
permettre à nos équipiers dans les
bassins et de décaler dans toute
sécurité ces masques permettront de
fonctionner pendant ce mois
mais un autre projet durable et en
actions nous avons monté une usine de
production de masques tissus et puis il
ya une production pays quand je je mets
en place cette unité de production
ça c'est aussi aux bénéficiaires du rsa
près de 200 personnes bénéficiant du rsa
sont venus et bien sûr vont être
indemnisés de quoi produire 300 milles
masque en tissu par mois une action
collective fruit de la mobilisation des
bénéficiaires du rsa
[Musique]